let's jump to gun control because um
the house has passed gun control package
sending at joe biden's desk after
mcconnell and other republicans defy
trump and vote for the bill no um let me
let me tell you they did not defy trump
they defied the will of their voter base
yes and i will not forget shelley moore
capito in west virginia what you did
because you are a scumbag i am rightly
pissed off about this
second most trump supporting state in
the country and she's not for reelection
for four years so she thinks she can get
away with this that she can she can spit
on our constituents as if west
virginians want gun control well thank
god for missouri because in missouri we
have the second amendment preservation
act and this is a law
that was passed two years ago signed by
the governor mike parson that
effectively
punishes missouri police officers
and their institution whichever one that
they are part of with a fifty thousand
dollar fine if missouri police officers
are to act in coordination with federal
officers enforcing federal laws if they
are not
against the law in missouri so if you
breaking missouri law then the police
officers can participate but in missouri
if uh if joe biden passes a gun control
package and it's not in missouri's law
then missouri police officers are not
allowed to participate and we still can
but not the missouri police we also have
from governor.nh.gov
hb1178 signed into law an act
prohibiting the state from enforcing any
federal statute regulation or
presidential executive order that
restricts or regulates the right of the
people to keep and bear arms
so this so the state
cannot
the feds can come in but not the states
missouri i mean i think i don't know how
relevant that is sorry
i think
my understanding of the federal law
is that it provides funding and support
to states in implementing their own red
flag laws am i am i mistaken well this
is not about it's not about red flags
this is about this is about the nfa this
is about any restriction on any gun
that's not codified in new hampshire
it's it's not nullification but it's
something similar in a sense right like
like we want i mean well there's things
like that happen in context outside of
gun where the state's like we're not
going to help the feds it's common
sanctuary sort of like sanctuary states
i mean the feds can't force the state to
spend their money and resources
enforcing federal law right right and
that's so that's that's what it would be
um so you're not stopping the feds from
coming in obviously but if they do come
in your police officers are totally
unable to help bless unless they want to
if they want to perform a federal raid
for bump stocks then missouri police
officers are not allowed to participate
and the police don't like it and it
actually has put conservatives in
missouri in a really difficult position
because typically they would de facto
support police
and so now police are you know in a
situation where they have to try and
convince conservative lawmakers to try
and repeal or gut a law that the
lawmakers just passed overwhelmingly
that was popular and it's now a big
campaign issue in missouri i don't know
that new hampshire's has any kind of an
enforcement clause but
there's a current senate candidate named
eric greitens who's running in missouri
he was governor there for a short time
he's now running again to be in the u.s
senate and he actually came on my
program uh in missouri and said that he
supported the police that this amounts
to a defunding of the police he was
actually using leftist rhetoric mom's
demand rhetoric going against this
second measurement preservation act
because of the fifty thousand dollar
fine that goes to those police
departments well i guess it does amount
to a de facto defunding in police but
because missouri conservatives are more
inclined to support gun gun rights than
they are to support the police
it puts republicans in a really
difficult spot i think it's actually a
beautiful thing to do i hope more states
copy us no i hear you and i just want to
mention if anyone had any illusions that
the police will not enforce gun control
laws or come take your guns because
they're conservatives this clearly
demonstrates that they will uh is it the
kind of thing where if two cops in a cop
car come and do it that it's a hundred
grand like 50 000 twice them in the
partner precedent right so if you have
if there's a gun raid and the fbi is
asking for local law enforcement to help
participate which happens all the time
because usually it's really it's
actually about money because what they
want to do is civil asset forfeiture
because we have this thing called
equitable sharing and the process is
that they come in they do a raid the
states the state takes some of the money
the feds take some of the money they
split the proceeds and then they walk
out happy but the state police officers
are mad because if they aren't breaking
a missouri state law they can't
participate with the feds and they can't
share in the spoils of war right so
that's really the issue is the the
question of how much money that these
police departments are losing and and
that's why i think it's a critical issue
because it places
conservative values against the law and
when conservatives are asked whether or
not they're going to support the police
or to support gun rights
the rights are what's more important
than the cultural we support police you
know rah-rah-rah kind of thing right so
i think it's a rubber hits the road
issue for anybody running for political
office ask them about missouri staple
law ask them about what new hampshire is
doing here and i wonder you know from a
constitutional question
what do you think will of the question
of the real deal the real nullification
which we had a crisis of which we had a
civil war
notifications nonsense sorry well go
ahead yeah no tell me about
i mean that was
that was settled in the 1860s can you
define what it is oh notification is the
right of a state to defy or uh over
somehow overturn federal law in its
jurisdiction
right and so the feds would not be able
in notification we would the police
officers would actually prevent the feds
from enforcing their rights aren't they
doing that in some places though
no i mean they're the only thing that
they've done is like they've you know
states can say basically do what they're
doing here which is like we will not
help you right like not not that we're
saying that your law doesn't apply here
but rather we will not help you enforce
your law like that's your problem if you
want to come in and enforce it you have
the right to do that go for it but we're
not going to help you enforce federal
law that's okay because state and
federal government are different
sovereigns right but and that's not a
disrespect of federal sovereignty
because it's still saying the federal
government has the right to enforce its
law and anywhere in the united states um
i i mean a world where you accept
nullification is a world where uh you
know new york says that's fascinating
that you have this new rule that says we
can't stop people from you know we can't
have our concealed weapons thing yeah
that's funny that you have that second
amendment but we're going to do what we
want new york and if that means
depriving everyone of their right to
guns you have no say in it we're going
to nullify
that that supreme court ruling like nah
right that i i think that's hold on hold
on that's what they're trying to do i
hear you i hear you and i think you're
making good arguments and i'm not
totally on one side or the other here
but i would say this i might be willing
to accept that if that meant in my state
the federal government gets zero say and
can't enforce anything if if our
legislatures decide that i should be
able to have whatever gun i want
ultimately what but you know ultimately
the the end state of nullification is is
going back to effectively the world of
the united states and the articles of
confederation right right it is the ends
of and i'm like no
actually historically that was terrible
and i don't want civil war in the united
states but that's how we get there right
like we want to go back to a world where
we had a very weak federal government
and and i mean ultimately that there was
a very very well i gotta be honest we
got a pretty strong federal government i
don't know about civil wars out of the
questions yeah no i mean
actually you know this is probably where
i disagree with you all i think we
actually do have a very strong federal
government and i think that as a result
of that civil war is totally out of the
question but if the federal government
were to pass a law that were to ban guns
federally right then the state says no
actually we're going to nullify that
because we actually interpret the
constitution as it is clearly written i
mean you'd be you'd be in favor of the
feds being able to enforce a law that
would ban guns federally if the state
wanted to nullify it you would be no the
state can't do that the civil war uh i
mean as like
i mean obviously i think you know the
hypothetical has a problem because the
state could go to court and say this is
fed this is unconstitutional under the
second amendment and you know we know
how that would end up now right because
the supreme court would say so but just
as a matter of principle right like i
don't think you know if on any random
litigated issue if the state disagrees
with the federal government but the you
know and they litigate you know the
federal wants government wants to impose
its all on the state the state litigates
and all the courts say no the federal
government can do this it's clearly
within federal authority i don't think
the state then just gets to defy that
under that scenario would you be in
favor of a convention of states
i mean i'd be in favor of changing
articles
i would be in favor of changing federal
law at that point are there no
circumstances where you think article
five of the constitution would ever
uh i don't want in a revolution man
revolutions are generally bad damn i
would think i want a revolution
they never turn out the way people think
they will like everything
we are like the only revolution that has
ever stuck the landing ever like i mean
think about how bad but hold on well
it's 20 years of conflict and death and
fighting sticking the landing i mean
that's as good as it gets right and
right and i think it turned out really
we're extremely lucky at the founding
fathers because you look at canada right
now and it's like but they warned us
over and over about central banks and i
mean they they were like they're more
powerful than standing armies i think
they even said at one point and then the
federal reserve got formed
yeah well i mean you're you're a
jeffersonian and i'm a hypocrite right
the federal reserve was a revolution
right the progressive era was a
revolution it wasn't fought with bullets
it was fought at the ballot box and so
yeah i want a revolution i don't want
fighting in the streets here in the
united states but i want an overturning
of many of the legal precedents that
have been set then you know win some
elections and and may and win some
litigation yeah i'm working i'm working
on that
revolution four more states for a
convention revolution means to turn
forward and it actually it's it's
constantly we're in a revolution we are
revolving and if you participate in the
revolution is up to you but it's
revolving whether you're doing it or not
30 states are controlled by republicans
the legislatures and for 34 for a
convention of states i believe i mean if
we had like we what we have now on the
supreme court in terms of a majority
with these states where we had more
majority of conservative states that
were pushing for this
then would you push for an article five
or think that oh you mean if we didn't
have a majority if we did i mean since
we have a majority supreme court
conservative supreme court i'm like
let's why we don't need to do anything
crazy let's just keep litigating yes and
winning uh like i mean think about how
much how much it must how depressing
must you be if you're a progressive
right now like you control the
presidency in both houses of congress
and you're taking l after
yeah do you want that in your back
pocket though do you want an article 5
convention to stay in the constitution
and to be something that's there you
don't even want the that power i don't
want like i really do not you know
people talk about national divorce i am
like a very anti-national divorce guy
i'm actually with you on that i think i
think people are wildly underestimating
how violent bloody that would be how
impossible that would be relative to i
mean
i think one thing we say most impossible
basis effectively i mean yeah me failed
english that's something
i was like
it's not it's not 1860 the you know in
the run-up to the civil war right after
civil war was declared state armies
literally just walked into federal
armories and took all the guns
the federal government was so weak we
don't we can't even comprehend how weak
the federal government was in the run-up
to the civil war which is why the states
were able to succeed in the first place
uh it just it's just not something that
would happen and it would be bad if it
did how strong is too strong a federal
government for you
um a federal i mean a federal government
that can't be constrained by law at all
is is too strong then you have you know
that there's no legal recourse that
there's no you don't think they were
there not even what do you think about
the federal government is not too strong
in your mind uh i mean there are places
where i think the federal government
should be weaker in places where i think
the federal government should be
stronger are you out are you comfortable
are you comfortable with the patriot act
with the patriot act i'm comfortable
with some things in the patriot act like
i think it probably gives the nsa and
like there's probably too much power and
too much espionage power in general but
but not with the new one
sorry i want to know will's talking
about the
federal reserve oh yeah sure yeah i'm
sorry man
get out
yeah
i will also say this on the question of
revolutions right people need to realize
this
this is true of basically every
revolution that i'm familiar with right
not a giant history buff you're right
the american revolution in many ways
stuck the landing but even with the
american revolution it's not as if every
single person who was revolting was
fighting because they wanted the kind of
system that the founding fathers ended
up setting up and we see this in every
like you look at the bolshevik
revolution it's not as if or even the
french revolution it's not as if all
those people rose up to fight because
they wanted to see the ideology that
ended up taking the place of their
current system come to fruition they
were angry they wanted to fight but it's
just a very tiny organized minority that
ends up get getting to decide what
government you have after the revolution
has won or has been won
if there is anything right now that is
making the federal government weaker
it's what the doj is doing with trump
supporters oh yeah yes
that that outright with with the
solitary confinement with the rating on
jeffrey clark with the subpoenas to gop
it is basically sending a signal to half
this country that the government is
against you
and that that means if you're if you're
someone who supported trump you believe
trump or you have you are a simple
skeptic who has questions based on uh
the texas v pennsylvania lawsuit or
things like that
you are being told your your your wants
concerns are irrelevant and you will get
no reaches of grievances and if that's
the case it's exactly what ends up
happening it's it's it's it's it is in
line with what happened in 18 in the 18
1860. when southern states felt like
their uh what was supposed to be granted
to them in terms of the federal
negotiations between states they weren't
getting what they were they were
supposed to be granted
it's a little i think it's a little
different i mean the way the way i'd
look at the south is the south felt
like you know to that they were on a
track to inevitably lose complete power
because like basically they they were on
track to be a permanent and how is that
different it's not just that it's um
one of the big issues with the fugitive
slave act yeah which is the north was
not adhering to and so you have many
southern states outright being like
so our votes are meaningless the federal
government won't enforce the the the
agreements that we have as a union then
there must not be a union and if that's
happening now with the doj going after
trump's peter navarro steve bannon
jeffrey clark going after a gop chair in
nevada filing subpoenas raiding homes
these people are going to have the exact
same sentiment i think i think i mean
the the way to resolve that is to
punish them when we take power right
like i think that that's we need we need
to kind of flip it back on them right
everybody who is involved in these doj
investigations themselves needs to come
under investigation there needs to be
like trump could have subpoenas trump
couldn't do it but then i'm thinking you
gotta look at a world where desantis and
a little more sophistic legally
sophisticated uh group of people are in
charge of a republican white house like
and and i'm just more vengeful like
yeah i think i think the optimism is
the the the midterms are going to be
really good for republicans and then in
2024 you're going to get
either a trump or desantis who will take
those actions but i just feel like
that's just it's unpredictable yeah no
and doj what doj is doing now and what
garland is doing at doj i mean merrick
allen should be impeached that actually
should be early on the list of things
like of what should be done for what um
for uh
various i mean there's a lot of unlawful
act there's actually like some seriously
like unlawful actions failure to enforce
law yep um right failure for example
like the protests at judges justice's
houses like his decision to just
completely not enforce that in my view
that's impeachable oh yeah absolutely
did he argue that was the first
amendment right he just didn't even i
don't even think he yeah discussed it
publicly like at all i think i i think
he passively just uh
i think it was asked of him but he said
something
like just chugging it off
if you're not gonna protect supreme
court justices from pro you know like
there's federal law on the books that
says people aren't allowed to protest in
front of their private homes but doesn't
the first amendment supersede that no
i mean the the precedent is that it's a
time there cannot be a first there
cannot be free speech without justice
so the exception made in terms of
protest is that courts must be free from
the influence of partisans therefore
your your your right to speak but not to
influence the you are not allowed to
pressure the courts through protests
well but there's a i guess the real
reason that's acceptable is it's a time
place and manner restriction right like
it's saying like you're allowed to
protest you just can't do it in front of
their private home
right and you know that that's what
those rules say and and they're that's
the procedural the the sort of
ideological is
if the courts aren't allowed to uh sit
down discuss and try and figure out what
justice is then free speech doesn't
exist at all well but they can i mean
they can still protest at the court
right no they can't sure they can um uh
i'm pretty sure it actually says you
cannot attempt to
protest at a court to persuade an
officer i'm
well as applied that would certainly be
unconstitutional right like if they
actually tried to that would certainly
be a first amendment violation to say
you couldn't protest i could be wrong
with that there's a difference
there's a difference of yelling at the
judge as he's driving to the court
standing outside and just yelling
outside the court while they're all
inside because if you're yelling at his
car and yelling at him when he's walking
in that's definitely pressure
let's clarify
i uh you guys talking a lot about the
civil war and the the allegory which i
see which is the states being like
you're not upholding my rights
government but i think of the the
revolutionary war and the similarities
that the taxation no taxation without
representation is what sparked it and as
they're printing trillions we've got
like 30 trillion dollars of debt that's
a tax on me and i'm not seeing that
money i got i just wanted sorry just i
want to clarify yes you cannot at a
court it says whoever with the intent of
interfering with obstructing or impeding
the administration of justice or with
the intent of influencing any judge
juror witness or court officer in the
discharge of his duty pickets or parades
in or near a building housing a court of
the united states or in or near a
building or residence occupied or used
by such a judge juror witness or court
officer
or with such intent uses any sound truck
or similar device or resorts to any
other demonstration in or near any such
building or residence shall be found in
this title imprisoned not more than one
year or both how do you define near i
guess it's probably yeah i mean that
actually you know that's an interesting
question because i guess the somehow
that's got to coexist with the first
amendment right so then there's like
i don't know there's i i guess i'd have
to read up on the what the how the
supreme i know the supreme court well so
what i read was the the the reason this
came about it's 1950
was because
the the the
the judges were basically like how can
we actually administer justice if people
will use political attacks against us in
in the course of seeking justice so
if you're able to protest at someone's
house or at a court to influence a judge
and alter the course of justice then
there isn't any because that means like
with brett kavanaugh
if he says i am going to side with
overturning roe v wade and they go then
we're gonna go to your house and and
threaten you then there's not justice
for those who had filed a petition in
the court it kind of reminds me of
remember back to the tommy robinson
stuff right right in the uk though it
was in the uk but it's sort of similar
interviewed someone outside of court so
they arrested him he really just talked
about right private you know like
what it was declared confidential
information about court proceedings and
wow
big brain stuff man yeah i know as a
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there